[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan did I mention a
question from one of my face book
readers godson who wrote insane I want
to go into the magazine publication
business and I don't have any capital of
my own to start off but I need your
advice and how to go into magazine
publication so thanks for the question
and it's great to see you on facebook i
love my facebook readers
two quick tips for you first i would
look at going to find a job working for
somebody who's in that business if you
haven't had any experience in the
magazine business before go try to work
with somebody else who's already doing
what you want to do it'll do a couple
things for you first it'll teach you
about the industry so you'll make some
contacts you'll learn how to ropes what
the ropes are you'll learn how to do the
business you'll be able to see you know
how to basically run the day-to-day
operations so that when you do go out
and start your own business you know
what to do and what not to do so you're
basically getting paid to make all the
mistakes and learn on somebody else's
watch the second thing that will teach
you is do you want to do this business
or not so sometimes we get excited about
companies instead of a business ideas
but then once we get into it we realize
hey there's a lot of work or this isn't
what I thought it was gonna be you know
it's a great dream but I really feel
like I should be doing something else
and that's okay it's good that start
small test see if it's for you or not so
by going to work for somebody else you
get those contacts you get the the
experience and the connections but it
also teaches you if you should be doing
this business or not and again you're
doing it all on somebody else's dime and
so you're not spending your own money
yet to do it it'll be my first tip the
second thing is I always love as much as
possible to try to create a business
without spending any money so I'll
invest my time energy effort blood sweat
tears but not my money into starting
something new and so I try to encourage
entrepreneurs who's the same thing so
your long term goal may be to create a
magazine publication as your business
that's awesome how can you start that
off on a smaller scale where you're not
spending any money and one place you
might look to is the web so create a web
version of whatever magazine you're
trying to do if it's a lifestyle or
sports or whatever it is create a
website you're gonna need a website
anyway for your magazine and a lot of
magazines are even going to the web and
shutting down their magazines because
it's hard to keep up with the economic
model of having a print magazine but
start online and you'll start making
connection
and start getting some good story ideas
out there and it doesn't cost you a lot
of money to create a website or
hopefully any money compared to actually
creating the physical magazine and that
will help you start to grow the business
and if you can start charging some
advertising rates on there and make some
money and then pour that that profit
back into your business you will to
expand into hopefully your magazine
publication so just those two quick
things those are my quick tips for you
got Santa to get you past the hump one
can work for somebody else has already
done what you're trying to do to learn
from them and see if this is the type of
business that you want to do and to
figure out a way to start small without
spending any money I would personally
look at doing it online to start you may
find other ways through partnerships or
through working with another company at
the same time to launch a magazine but
again without spending any money try to
figure that out bootstrap it up and then
you can be able to expand from there one
last one last thought a lot of
entrepreneurs do try to go out and raise
capital for their business and it's
great it's a it's a great potential idea
that the two things to keep in mind
first of all it takes up a lot of time
so raising capital so I should be going
for angel Capital or venture capital it
almost becomes a full-time job and that
takes away from you being able to
actually run your business so I'd rather
invest that time into making my business
run and and launch instead of just
having the idea on paper that I'm
pitching around to investors the second
thing is if you were at the really early
stage you're gonna get killed on your
valuation if you go to a bank you're
gonna have to pay really high interest
rates if you go to any kind of other
investor equity investor they're gonna
take a big chunk of your company just
because you have an idea and you haven't
actually launched your business so the
more you can get momentum building some
real customers coming in even if you're
not making a lot of money but you're
making some money then if you need to
make money to go to expand and get get
some angel or venture capital investors
involved you'll get a much better
valuation because you have a lot more of
a track record behind you so hopefully
that helps godson for those of you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up makes fun of do more
videos for you and I'd love to hear what
you have to think you can leave a
comment under the video or if you have a
question for your own business I always
love hearing those so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]